hey this is presh talwalkar
i received this question from tim in
singapore
it was given to 10 year olds who had not
yet studied algebra
i slightly edited the problem for
clarity
the total amount of sand contained in
boxes a b and c is 360 grams
each box starts with some unknown amount
of sand and a mathematician decides to
play with the sand
first the mathematician pours one-sixth
of the sand for box a into box b
after that the mathematician pours one
third of the sand in box b into box c
finally the mathematician pours one
fifth of the sand in box c into box a
at the end each box has an equal amount
of sand
how much sand did each box have at the
beginning
now remember this was given to 10 year
olds who had not yet studied algebra so
you should try to solve this problem
without using a system of simultaneous
equations
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so the way i solve this problem is to
work backwards
we'll create a table with the amounts in
each box
and we'll let the amounts be in grams so
we can drop the units and just focus on
the numbers
so by working backwards that means to
start at the very end
how much sand is in each box at the very
end
the problem tells us each box has an
equal amount of sand at the end and the
total amount of sand is 360 grams
so at the very end each box has 360
divided by 3 which is 120 grams
so we can fill in these amounts in the
table
now let's go one step backwards
how much is in each box before the step
where box c gets poured into box a
well the mathematician pours one fifth
of box c into box a
so if box c minus one fifth of itself
equals 120 then box c must have had 120
times five fourths which equals 150
before the sand was poured out
we can see this by a little bit of
algebra if we have box c times 1 minus 1
5
that's equal to 120
that means box c times four fifths is
equal to 120 so we take the reciprocal
of four-fifths which will be
five-fourths
therefore box c started with 120 times
five-fourths which equals 150.
so we can say that box c had 150.
now since
150 minus 120 is equal to 30 that's how
much was poured from c to a
we can deduce box a must have had 30
fewer grams before the step 120 minus 30
which equals 90.
furthermore pouring from box c to box a
leaves box b unaffected so box b
remained at 120.
now let's go one more step backwards
what happened before box b was poured
into box c
if box b minus one third of itself
equals 120 then box b had 120 times
three halves which equals 180 before
this step
furthermore since this step transferred
60 grams from b to c we know that box c
had 60 fewer grams or 150 minus 60 which
equals 90 before this step
and box a was unaffected in this step so
it remained at 90.
now we go back to the beginning what
happened before box a was poured into
box b
well
if box a minus 1 6 of itself equals 90
then box a had 90 times six-fifths which
equals 108 before the sand was poured
out
furthermore we see that 18 grams was
transferred from a to b
therefore box b must have started with
180 minus 18 which equals 162.
box c was unaffected in this episode
remained at 90.
and there you go
these are the starting amounts
box a had 108 box b had 162 and box c
had 90 grams
so it's a fairly challenging problem to
ask of 10 year olds but it can be solved
with logical considerations and by
working backwards
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can catch
me on social media either at mind your
decisions or at preshtalwalker